Democrats are putting all their candy in
a new basket of candidates this
Halloween and the result for Americans
can be downright nauseating here is
Democratic gubernatorial hopeful Andrew
Gilliam on the trick he has in store for
Florida voters you do want to raise
taxes on businesses so be correct I
believe that businesses ought to pay
their fair share
you do want Medicare for all I do
believe that health care ought to be a
right and not a privilege so you would
acknowledge that you are perhaps more
progressive progressive I wouldn't deny
any day of the week
everything's free no one has to pay
anything now I can't imagine that this
is what Florida voters really want
higher taxes more spending and more
regulations that will end up choking
their states now thriving economy and
then there's another charismatic leftist
Stacey Abrams running for governor of
Georgia now she is a positively spooky
view of basic economics
[Music]
yeah let's have state price controls
that always work well for the United
States or any country why waste time
with capitalism when socialist
redistribution seems you know like so
much more fair well Abraham's is
currently running neck-and-neck with
Republican Secretary of State Brian Kemp
and now she's trying to connect with the
regular folks by bringing in mega star
power Oprah coming into town and she's
hoping to be the queen maker in Georgia
and comedian Will Ferrell is going
door-to-door to canvas for Abrams hoping
that you think he's a real anchorman who
knows something about politics former
President Barack Obama and senator
Bernie Sanders are also expected in
Georgia next week and meanwhile
President Barack Obama heads down to
Florida on Friday totally unfazed by the
new revelations that his guy Andrew
Gilliam was again shown to be corrupt of
course what he did well he used taxpayer
funds from his mayoral office to take a
private plane to meet with his donors to
his gubernatorial run when confronted on
his corruption gilliam runs to race I
don't take free trips from anybody I'm a
hardworking person I know that may not
fit your description of what you think
people like me do but I worked hard for
everything that I've gotten in my life
and I don't need anybody handing me
anything for free now that subtext
wasn't too hard to read his frequent
trick of course is used to deflect
questions about his own Tallahassee
sleaze by claiming that his opponent
Republican Ron De Santis is just a
blatant racist I do think that mr.
DeSantis is have been given too much
harbor to racists and xenophobes and
anti-semites he's spoken at conferences
with them he authored a book justifying
slavery okay now that's just a
bald-faced lie Ron de santis wrote a
book justifying racism of slavery I mean
as a wonder he was ever elected to the
House of Representatives well we pulled
the book it's called Dreams from our
founding fathers
and in it DeSantis four counts how
Alexander Hamilton and Benjamin Franklin
lamented the quote notorious compromises
that were made to tolerate slavery so
the Constitution could actually pass he
could form a government here's the
quotation for anti-slavery delegates
like Hamilton and Franklin abolition of
slavery would be a moot point if a
failure to erect a functioning
government snuffed out the ideals of the
American Revolution and their infancy
then the future of all Americans the
free as well as a slave would eventually
be as serfs to a despotic government the
recitation of historical fact is not
racist nor is it justifying slavery and
either Andrew Gilliam is just really not
all that smart or he's purposely lying
about something this awful and horrible
it's defamatory
and it should not be tolerated or
rewarded by the voters of Florida but of
course racism seems to be one of the
most potent forces that the Democrats
have in their trick bag this midterm
season
everywhere you turn the refrain is the
same what I did wrong in 2016 is that
overestimated white people I didn't
think white people would put him in
office so here he is running around the
country appealing to our darker angels
appealing to our hatreds and fears and
I'm supposed to believe that Delaware
County and Ohio is not going to vote for
him that the suburbs in Pennsylvania
aren't going to vote for him if the
evidence is there what do you want me to
do lie about it I'm a journalist I have
to give the facts in the truth the truth
and the evidence points to him being a
racist he's a racist this is race
baiting taken to a new low if it's even
possible to go any lower rather than
mount credible arguments in the face of
Trump's success it's easier to tar him
and all Republicans who ever supported
him as racists or just members of the
Third Reich
they're completely race obsessed on the
left
here's Indiana's Democratic Senator Joe
Donnelly who recently attempted to brag
about some of his employees or at least
about their ethnicity our state director
is indian-american but he does an
amazing job our director of all
constituent services she's
african-american but she does an even
more incredible job than you could ever
imagine I don't know what that is takes
your breath away and at a moment when
the country is focused on immigration
and securing the border Texas Democratic
superstar bado robber Francis O'Rourke
dropped this Treat on MSNBC's Chris
Matthews he slipped it in his view of
the border while talking about how he
met his wife we met on a blind date in
El Paso before tinder and took her over
the bridge to sue that wad is her sister
city had a margarita at the Kentucky
club and we just we just really hit it
off and I told that story to folks to
kind of remind them of the binational
nature of the us-mexico border somehow
somewhere that passes as really
intelligent the binational nature of the
border well a border is between two
countries right so there are two but
what does that mean by national nature
that there are two distinct nations and
a border should be protected Robert but
now compare all those Democratic tricks
the tax hikes the empty racism charges
the vision of a open border abolishing
ice all that stuff to Trump streets now
under this president this news came out
today wages and salaries rose 3.1% in
the third quarter the biggest increase
in a decade the GDP expanded by a three
point five percent annual rate ahead of
the three point four percent expectation
African American and Hispanic
unemployment are at historic lows and
the president is taking real steps like
sending 5,000 troops of the border to
protect our sovereignty and your bottom
line your wallet you'll know the
Democrats don't really offer any cogent
argument or response alternative to the
Trump record because they expect to win
via
a sustained campaign of anti-trump anger
and race-baiting but like old Halloween
candy none of that's going to satisfy or
sustain the country
and it'll just give you a really bad
aftertaste in your mouth it's kind of
bitter and that's the angle